hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to helps students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well one particularly interesting and I
think very insightful essay that Ursa
kayen writes near the end of her life
Publishing in no time to spare is called
about anger and she begins in a kind of
narrative or or history when anger
actually might have been much more
useful for accomplishing certain things
than it is in the present that we live
in now she's publishing this in
2017 and she tells us that in the
Consciousness raising days of the second
wave of feminism we made a big deal out
of anger the anger of women we praised
it and cultivated it as a virtue we
learned to boast of being angry to
Swagger our rage to play The Fury and so
what are we talking about we're talking
about like you know the 1960s 70s going
into the
1980s and why was it so important to
articulate and recover anger that was
there because it had been suppressed for
so long women had you know been placed
in circumstances where they were
discouraged from sometimes even punished
for displaying the anger that they
rightly had due to all sorts of various
forms of discrimination and exploitation
and even domination and abuse now was
that a mistake according to Leen not
exact exctly but she talks about this as
a time of feminism's uh childhood if
feminism was the baby at that time she
says it's now grown past that she says
we were right to do so we were telling
women who believe they should patiently
patience is like uh traditionally
conceived as an opposite to anger right
patiently endure insults injuries and
abuse that they had every reason to be
angry we're rousing people to feel and
see Injustice the methodical
mistreatment to which women were
subjective the almost Universal
disrespect of human rights of women and
to resent and refuse it for themselves
and she goes on and she's going to bring
up another term that she'll use at
multiple points here indignation now a
lot of people mistake anger and in
indignation for being exactly the same
thing for Leen they're not she says IND
tion forcibly expressed is an
appropriate response to Injustice
indignation draws strength from outrage
outrage draws strength from Rage there
is a time for anger and that those early
years was such a time now the wrong
lessons sometimes get drawn about the
usefulness of say an emotion or a
certain strategy in one time in one
situation and turning it into a
universal she talks about anger as being
a weapon or as a tool and she says that
it's really only useful in combat and
self-defense now self-defense legitimate
right there could be problems in going
too far with one's anger as we'll look
at in just a bit combat is a bit more of
a neutral term
and this is where you know she talks
about the backlash against feminism uh
people to whom male dominance is
important or essential fear women's
resistance therefore they fear women's
anger because they know a weapon when
they see one and she says listen if
women actually behaved like people on
the rightwing who are critics of
feminism typically do behave displaying
the level of Ang anger and even like
outright rage that those people
typically do in fact display and
encourage well they would be targeted
immediately as a matter of fact just the
amount of anger that they do show gets
them like she says those who see human
rights as consisting of men's rights
labeled every woman who spoke up for
Justice as a man-hating bra burning
intolerant shrew with much of the media
supporting their view they degraded the
meaning of the words feminism and
feminist identifying them with
intolerance and that's the situation
that we see today where many people as
soon as they hear those words they have
all sorts of crazy ideas in their head
about what they actually mean which
they've generally gotten from somewhere
right they didn't just come up with it
out of their own experiences or their
own Reflections they're basically just
parting other people's talking points
and they identify women's anger when
expressed as being intolerant motivated
by hatred and then they behave hatefully
towards them and she says the farri
likes to see everything in terms of
warfare right and she goes on and she
says Okay so we're in a different
situation now if we want to actually
work for justice for what she calls
gender rights then we're not going to
get it through anger uh by itself mere
anger now seldom proves a useful tool
and she now notice the again a
distinction indignation is still the
right response to indignity to
disrespect but in the present moral
climate it seems to be most effective uh
expressed through steady Resolute
morally committed behavior and action so
indignation could go that way towards
working for justice in a let's say more
calm manner or it could be channeled
into anger and rage which uh is not
going to be as effective anymore and so
what is she talking about here the
political or public role and she says um
you know anger is helpful because it
points to the denial of rights but the
exercise of Rights can't live and thrive
on anger what can it actually live and
thrive on the dogged pursuit of Justice
which doesn't need anger necessarily as
a motivator or as a fuel and she says
you know if things get worse we may have
to call upon anger as a weapon again but
we're not at that point yet and I hope
nothing we do now brings us closer to it
now you know this is uh several years
ago and perhaps I think if legine were
around today she might say well now we
actually do need it but in 2017 when
this is published she is saying H not
quite as effective and why not well
there are some problems that come up
with valuing anger for its own sake
which was in her view the right response
back then when you know second wave
feminism as activism as social
transformation was in its infancy now
not really the right response why anger
continued on past its usefulness becomes
unjust and then dangerous so instead of
being a tool that automatically works
for justice to reduce danger to to women
or to whoever else it ends up going too
far and becoming Injustice and becoming
dangerous she says nursed for its own
sake value doesn't end in itself it
loses its goal now I think that you know
if we wanted to paraphrase this what we
have to say by losing its goal it loses
its legitimate goal or rather it winds
up being steered into other goals other
ends other purposes than what it was
originally intended to do she says it
fuels not positive activism but
regression
Obsession Vengeance
self-righteousness and she says the
racism misogyny and counter rality of
the reactionary right in American
politics is a frightening exhibition of
the Del liberate force of anger
deliberate destructive force of anger
deliberately nourished by hate
encouraged to rule thought invited to
control behavior and she talks about an
orgy of self-indulgent Rage that is
besetting our political fabric at at the
time that she's writing this and I think
she's quite right about that anger when
valued when Justified for its own sake
does go astray it
changes its goal right and so political
anger she says all right maybe not as
useful now but what about private anger
what about anger in our personal
relationships in our interactions for
example while traveling or engaging in
economic activity in the workplace in
buying and selling and dealing with our
neighbors maybe there's some good role
for anger there she says
um I find the subject very troubling why
because I want to see myself as a woman
of strong feeling but Peaceable
instincts I have to realize how often
anger fuels my acts and thought how very
often I indulge in anger so she's you
know coming clean about this in a way
that I think is quite refreshing and she
says that you know anger can be useful
but only in certain circumstances so she
talks about brief and open expression an
outburst of anger that can cleanse the
soul and clear the air she says a brief
open expression of anger now notice
these these two
qualifiers in the right moment aimed at
its true Target is effective right so
anger at an abuser who is actually
engaging and abuse could be quite
helpful could be needed in that
situation however
when anger lacks those qualifications
when it's not brief when it's not open
when it's um not at the right moment
when it's not aimed at the true
Target then we run into all sorts of
problems and so she says um a weapon is
appropriate to and Justified only by a
situation of danger right uh anger
nursed and nourished begins to act like
anger suppressed it begins to poison the
air with vengefulness spitefulness
distrust breeding Grudge and resentment
brooding endlessly over the causes of
The Grudge the righteousness of the
resentment it takes on an energy a
pattern a dynamic an orientation of its
own what it is that we find negative in
uh the emotion of anger the danger the
Injustice that can arise from it and
then she goes into a very interesting
analysis of the sources of anger she she
does note at the end that anger does
tend to provoke more anger right
suppressing anger provokes anger
expressing anger you know may also
produce anger but she talks about one
positive source of anger and she says um
I recognize one for me and this doesn't
rule out the possibility of other
positive sources or aspects of anger she
says self-respect when slighted or
patronized I flare up in Fury and attack
right then right there I have no guilt
about it but there's a problem with this
it often turns out to have been a
misunderstanding the disrespect was not
intended or was mere clumsiness and even
if it was intended so what and so she
says all right I'm going to put that
aside that hasn't really been that
profitable to explore where is my anger
coming from and by extension where is
the anger of other people typically
coming from and she
says it's probably coming more from the
what she calls negatives jealousy which
she also connects to With Envy hatred
and
fear and so she says you know fear is uh
a common thing that comes up if I'm in
an angry mood I can ask myself what are
you afraid of some sometimes uh anger is
provoked because we're feeling out of
control we're feeling afraid about
things we're going to come back to that
in a moment what about jealousy or Envy
the two very closely related emotions
and for anybody who's confused about
those typically when we're saying
jealousy we mean that we're talking
about sort of a contested good that we
have some access to and we feel as our
own but others are threatening it they
could take it away so I'm jealous of
somebody else looking at my spouse and
flirting with them right uh whereas Envy
is a desire to have what another has and
feeling a kind of pain that they have it
and you don't have it so if I want the
candy bar that somebody else got in
their Halloween candy even though I
didn't go
trick-or-treating that's Envy that's not
jealousy um if I want to keep you from
from eating my candy bar hands off
that's jealousy so she says jealousy
sticks its nasty yellow green snout
mostly into my life as a writer and she
gives some examples I'm jealous of other
writers who SAR a success on wings of
Praise I'm
contemptuously angry at them and at the
people who praise them if I don't like
their writing and then she goes on and
she says um all this jealous anger
happens only if I don't like what they
write if I like a writer's writing
Praise of that writer makes me happy and
you can read which authors she's
actually talking about there and then
she says okay where is this coming from
jealousy of this sort is actually not
coming uh from itself but from Fear the
fear that if these other writers are
really the greatest there's no way I can
ever be very good or very highly
considered as as a writer because
there's no way I'm going to write
anything like what they write or please
the readers and critics that they please
and she says this comes from a kind of
insecurity right uh so a lot of times we
fear when we're envious I'm not going to
get what somebody else has or when we're
jealous I'm not going to get the share
of the good that I actually deserve you
know in relation to they're going to
take too much of it we're afraid and
then we get angry as a result what about
hatred so hatred and anger the
connection between them Way Way Back
Aristotle actually provides an analysis
of the difference between the two in the
rhetoric but the he also notes that
hatred can result from anger and both of
them together can lead to social
breakdown says anger so she says anger's
connection with hatred is surely very
complicated and I don't understand it
all but again fear seems to be
involved if you aren't afraid of someone
or something threatening or unpleasant
you can as a rule despise it ignore it
or even forget it if you fear it you
have to hate it and she says I guess
hatred uses anger as fuel I don't really
know um but there is this connection
between hatred and fear and anger and
she says when I'm coming away from it
though uh see seems to be a persuasive
idea that anger is connected with fear
what is it then that I actually fear and
again she's not giving you sort of a
comprehensive list this is just an essay
but the two things she does identify I
think many of us can relate to them fear
of being unsafe of somebody else putting
you in situations that could lead to
bodily harm or financial damage or your
reputation or take away opportunities
from you or or damage relationships
right and fear of not being in control
of having somebody else dominate exploit
abuse you right um and you know she
talks here about um anger perhaps being
a denial of the fear and the connection
between anger fear and depression as as
well she um also tells us that
suppressed anger itself comes from Pain
you suppress your anger why because if
you don't other people are going to hurt
you and they already have hurt you for
showing anger and then it leads to pain
because it is going to come out in other
ways maybe in a huge Outburst maybe in
passive aggressivity so pain is another
one of those things so we have quite a
few negative emotions all of which wind
up being connected with fear and pain
and anger itself and I want to close
this on two let's call them enigmas
rather than questions riddles things
that are not completely resolved in this
one of them involves a narrative a story
that she's going to tell and she says
that if there is a moral to this tale I
don't know what it is and what is the
story
well her mother tells her about a
psychiatrist who when Ursula kayen and
her you siblings were young uh told her
mother don't punish them don't hit them
when you're angry and her mother was
like okay I guess that makes sense and
then afterward she thought about it
she's like so wait a second are you
telling me I'm supposed to hit my kids
when I'm not angry with them that seems
kind of counterintuitive and why did she
actually bring this up because ursla
quate Ur Ursa Kaya Green's Child 2 years
old came over looked at her and then bit
her right on the leg while her mother
was there and URS Ken out of re reflex
backhand the child and the child you
know gets knocked away and then there's
like you know she says tears but no
apologies and everything goes back to
being normal and her mom tells her her
story and then also says by the way your
brother did this when he was 2 years old
and he kept doing it and then finally
one day I smacked him and he stopped
doing it and you know there it is and
you know we could say well you know we
we're sort of like kittens in that
respect when we're babies we do all
sorts of destructive things because
we're you know we're Predator creatures
we're not primarily prey creatures but
even they do goofy things like that and
Ursa Ken offers us this story for us to
think about she doesn't want us to jump
to a conclusion oh I know the answer to
the story she wants us to think about it
mul it over and if there is a moral
figure out what the moral is for ourself
she also ends on another sort of
question which is I would say related to
this and she
says what is the way to use anger to
fuel something other than hurt to direct
it away from hatred vengefulness
self-righteousness the the negative
aspects the ways in which anger becomes
unjust and dangerous and make it serve
creation and compassion now notice that
is different than saying when is my
anger Justified how can I use anger for
justice for addressing wrongs for
defending rights how can we go beyond
and use it for something more positive
like like
Compassion or Genuine creativity those
are in this essay also unresolved
questions and legine is perfectly fine
with leaving space for us to consider
these a little bit further going Beyond
her own
essay